[Music]
i wanted to show them something that
wasn't an illusion
[Music]
something that was real
something that they could
see and touch
creation
is an act of sheer will
life
will find a way
we can't keep her here forever
they find her we're never gonna see her
again we gotta protect her that's our
job
humans and dinosaurs can't coexist
[Music]
we created an ecological disaster
ellie settler
alan grant
you didn't come out all this way just to
catch up now did you
you coming or what
[Music]
we're racing toward the extinction of
our species
we not only lack dominion over nature
[Music]
we're subordinate to it
[Music]
[Music]
come back i always come back
that's another plane right
not exactly
don't move
bigger why do they always have to go
bigger
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
what threatened us with catastrophe
turned out to be our salvation
the new history of mankind begins
here and these very minutes
[Music]
[Music]
and the earth was cycles and empty
and the darkness
over the abyss
[Applause]
every night
i dreamed the same dream
then
the nightmare begins
i did what i had to do
to protect our world
you can't control everything strange
you open the doorway between universes
and we don't know who or what will walk
through it
wanda
what do you know about the multiverse
this had his theories
he believed it was dangerous
he was right
i'm sorry stephen
your desecration of reality
will not go unpunished
[Music]
we should tell him the truth
[Music]
things just got out of hand
[Music]
you break the rules look out
and become a hero
i do it i become the enemy
[Music]
that doesn't seem fair
[Music]
a year of work for a four-minute flight
isn't that something we're all ready if
you are sir well let's go find out if
this
we got a breach in the perimeter
thank you
[Music]
was like your mission log
after a full year of being marooned on
this planet
our first test flight is a go
[Music]
but get everyone home good luck
captaining
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
just a massive robot
[Music]
that was utterly terrifying and i regret
having joined you
i can provide sleep sounds if you like i
have several options summer night ocean
paradise whale calls no no white noise
is fine very well good night socks good
night buzz
[Music]
quick stretch little snack and here we
go
sonic i love that you want to help make
a difference
if you're being reckless don't worry
nobody's gonna get hurt
pretending to be batman blue justice
trademark pending
you're still just a kid
trust me there will come a moment when
your powers will be needed
but you don't choose that moment that
moment chooses you i just got goosebumps
wait a second did you steal that from
oprah
papa's got a brand new stash
since i've been gone i've discovered the
source of ultimate power
that sounds big
it's been on my vision board for years
hope i'm not too late
i'm sorry who are you
tails okay this is what we're gonna do
step one light taunting step two i have
no idea
[Music]
that wasn't too bad
today's forecast calls for a 100 chance
of adventure
[Music]
return to sender
face it you're never going to get my
power
do i look like i need your power
where
are my manners sonic meet knuckles
oatmeal glate light foam
hey
how's the mars boyfriend long distance
dating sucks how long have you guys been
a guy eight years eight years how did
you manage that he checks all the boxes
oh you mean literally strong jaw mental
fortitude six pack
[Music]
we had a plan and then he got his
martian dream job
so i enrolled in the mars program
you ever worry the wrong person is
headed to the wrong planet goodbye
forever walt
hello hey
what are you doing here who sneaks onto
spaceships i can explain
ever since i was a kid i dreamt of going
to mars
you can keep my dream alive come with me
you cannot under any circumstances leave
my room okay
this is gonna suck isn't it only for 35
days
you have to keep a low profile
[Music]
all right you guys i'm your captain this
is sophie my girlfriend long-term
girlfriend i don't remember you from
orientation
what happened
you have to come right back and just rip
his jumpsuit off
[Laughter]
hey what's up i just miss you sorry do
we have a call scheduled
come on let's go have some fun i don't
do fun you also don't fly on rockets or
conspire with stoneways sophie for walt
disney world 100 bucks since you just
said that in your wrist
you just gotta face it you're a space
criminal now
historic journey to make life more
meaningful
now
you've spent your entire life trying to
check an impossible set of boxes
i can't risk the plan when you find that
thing that you're willing to cross the
entire universe to be with
make sure it's ready to do the same for
you
[Music]
it doesn't matter how far you travel you
can never escape yourself did you just
come up with that no [ __ ] that is a
very common phrase
[Music]
come on yank
what are you doing
come on
[Music]
what happened to yang i don't know
shut down last night he won't restart
does this happen before no
[Music]
if we can't get young fixed
[Music]
i'm not going to buy another sibling for
mika
[Music]
it is an interior core problem
[Music]
i need your permission to break open the
core
we've always known that some bots are
equipped with spyware
you might not want a spot in your house
anymore
[Music]
i wish i had a real memory
what do you mean
[Music]
did you i want to be human
that's such a human thing to ask isn't
it
[Music]
i be honest with you wait
it's not being honest an option for you
[Music]
you want him back of course i do
i want him back too
i just need a little more
[Music]
time are you watching
[Music]
who are you under there
what are you hiding
my son dreamt of a better world that's
why he saved me
you can go to any timeline any universe
might fight to save this one
what could be greater than a
a
king
i just got goosebumps
[Music]
if we don't stand up no one will
come with us
it's a glorious world out there
waiting for you
are you in
[Music]
she's out
[Applause]
[Music]
tell me something
[Music]
you can go
anywhere you want right
any
timeline
and the universe
[Music]
why do you want to stay
and fight to save this one
you change the future
and you change the past
are you in
oh
[Music]
yes
michael
what have you done i was trying to help
people
but the cure
it's cursing
i have powers that can only be described
as superhumans
but there's a cost
now a face of choice to hunt
and consume blood
don't die
you all have monsters within us it's up
to us to control it
what if i can't
michael morvious
you've been given a gift
not exactly
time to let go of what you used to be
discover who you're meant to be
all our lives we've lived with death why
shouldn't they know what it feels like
for a change
just accept who you are
the bad guy
more bs
holy water really
yeah you ever see lost boys story of my
life
a new marvel legend arrives exclusively
in movie theaters april 1st
[Music]
baby
[Music]
you got a minute oh what
when how does how does she
how did you get
how have you been
it's a long story
is this the room you grew up in uh it is
but uh my my dorm room is very adorable
right no of course
hey are these your drawings what no no
good
i missed you too okay
so what are you doing here
i mean i
i thought i'd
never see you again
want to get out of here
[Music]
i'm
grounded
bummer
is spider-man grounded
um
i mean
[Music]
so oh
[Music]
[Music]
mrs wang are you with us
i am paying attention
now you may only see a pile of proceeds
but i see a story
i can see where this story is going
it does not look
good
what's happening
devlin
i'm not your husband i'm one of the
first
universe i'm here because we need your
help
very busy today so time to help you
across the multiverse
i've seen thousands of evelyn's
you can access all the memories their
emotions
even their skills
there's a great evil spreading like the
many verses
and you
maybe your only chance of stopping it
don't make me find you i am really good
i don't believe you
the universe he speaks of senseless
things is
i just wanted to share with you
remember our mission concerning the fate
of every single world of our infinite
motives
there is no way i am the eveline you are
looking for
every rejection
every disappointment
has led you here
to this
moment
don't let anything distract you from it
[Music]
[Music]
they say these are crazy times
everyone out for themselves
and one day i got a chance to sell my
soul
[Music]
you know what love is jack i've only
heard stories from a long time ago
you recently had any new type of
experience
like one
about the girl
why are they falling
the corporation won't stop until it has
you
the only chance is to stop seeing the
girl
what if i can't stay away from her
then
you will die
there isn't much time
you're deteriorating quickly
these people are very dangerous
and you should walk away
[Music]
you ever been scared
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you